oh you asked for this told you free I
like Halloween I like dressing up I'm
bad at planning I need her to have the
initiative and then she holds the whip
and says is what you're gonna wear I
don't have a whip [ __ ] I was younger I
never was able to get a Halloween
costume my dad would always give me the
Nigerian clothes here in the Nigerian
prince for Halloween didn't even get me
a crown I'm definitely not like into the
whole costume thing the only costume
Steve's ever worn was last year I was
Minnie Mouse and I bribed him into being
dead Mickey Mouse I think it frustrates
you a little bit that I like don't well
I get so into it maybe after this I'll
be inspired
I chose Abraham Lincoln you don't often
see black Abraham Lincoln's you don't
often see buff Abraham Lincoln's and you
don't often see Abraham Lincoln's with
like giant-ass glasses I like my
costumes to be a little bit historical
educational I chose Han Solo just
because I feel like Tyler looks great
and invest
there's something about Tyler that's the
like the classic Harrison Ford type man
were like he doesn't like to ask for
directions
I chose Zoolander for Stephen I've seen
it too many times this is my sly way of
trying to get him to do a couples
costume with me because I was thinking
about being Hansel
I have no clue what she could have
possibly picked out for me her like
reference point is so oh my guess is
Star Wars she knows that I love Star
Wars
I like Han cuz he's a maverick and he's
a little rogue
she gives me Luke says something about
me you mentioned that it's really cool
and that you would wear the thing you
picked right she keeps telling you that
she picked Barbie Barbie which I know
it's not that like this could be great
and this could be catastrophic this guy
even looks like me oh my god yeah of
course
yep this seems about right Halloween you
can be anyone you could ever imagine she
went with Abraham Lincoln console was
the greatest I said one time that I wish
that I was Han Solo but I'm probably
more of a Luke and now I feel like I've
graduated to Han Solo I don't know if I
can pull off Zoolander maybe she's into
dudes and big hats if my girlfriend
thinks that I'm like a space cowboy
that's pretty awesome Lucille it's like
a guy can't do it [ __ ] this is gonna be
harder than I thought
the thing I like about this costume is
it's a twofer one put it all on your
ibrahim lincoln or you can just throw
this on here to just Chippendales
but in tune but in tune I definitely
feel more like Han Solo right now then I
put it on the vest just feels weird
feels weird even for Halloween now you
can't tell that the guns are out and I'm
Abe Lincoln this is not the hottest solo
gun and I know this because I have the
actual Han Solo gun one man one beard
one cream this is going to
scare me away from trying Mecosta hmm
this is how I assumed he talked you look
great you would - loss Falls and 70
years ago
take a Bologna and put it in a ham
sandwich I'm Abraham Lincoln I'm nailing
the space cowboy look and I think I that
fits me isn't exactly what I wanted what
is this a center for ants right here I'm
Abraham Lincoln poem right now Magic
Mike to Channing Tatum Tyler Williams
space cowboy I know I put that on my
business card
yeah just just preview this is super
trendy right now babe you never look
better you should wear this out Steve
looks great and we're gonna look even
better when we go out as Zoolander and
Hansel I'm more confused now than I've
ever been in my entire life I feel like
I've opened this side of Tyler that I'm
not sure I should have opened was always
there say that you love me no I'm not
doing it
I know what you're gonna do try just
want to see what happens oh yeah I know
god damn it you're glowing he's cute
enough to be on a postage stamp
I knew you were gonna put your own spin
on it